c'est non non il est donc temps d'écouté
et requérir monsieur le procureur
général de la république des proches
française eh bien monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri c'est un homme brisé fourbus et
terriblement déçu qui vous parle
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
oui monsieur le président je suis
extrêmement là est déçu et croyez-moi ce
n'est pas seulement à cause de la nuit
que nous avons passé tous les cas de
josiane dans un g2
non monsieur le président je suis déçu
une fois de plus par la france
je suis déçu par la france qui sourde
aux appels angoissés de son immortel
destin civilisateur s'enfonce de jour en
jour plus profondément dans l'abîmé
infâme d'une décadence honni ou se
vautre les vaincus combien combien 3
qu'elle aurait volé dire quoi l'occuper
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas si la
france coule quand c'est parce qu'elle
est rongé de l'intérieur par ben par
d'ignobles asticots boulimique tels que
vous accusez jacques balutin vous qui
toute honte bue
j'adore dire tout le monde est lui même
un panneau vous jacques balutin qui
toute honte bue re prenait un plaisir
sadique à vous déguiser périodiquement
en sergent de ville demeuraient ou en
inspecteur tard et dans le seul but de
ridiculiser aux yeux du monde entier
notre belle police nationale kenyane qui
est pourtant l'une de nos plus
glorieuses institution avec le loto le
tiercé
la npa la loi anti-casseurs l'académie
française la légion d'honneur et la
contraception masculine par coïtus
interruptus amen
voilà voilà ce qui arrive mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
voilà ce qui arrive dans un pays où
l'égoïsme étriqué à supplanter l'esprit
civique dans un pays où l'on ne chante
plus où l'on de prix plus ou longues
guillotine ray pratiquement plus si je
n'étais pas là mais nous sommes là
mesdames et messieurs les jurés et nous
veillons et les fortes têtes nous les
machins monsieur bah luttons nous les
matons ses baluchons les fortes têtes
monsieur baluchon les fortes têtes
muller à chaud monsieur balutin je l' ai
déjà dit ici mesdames et messieurs les
jurés pour être procureur on en est pas
moins homme et sous la robe austère du
magistrat ce nom a été en retard est se
cache un coeur bombers un coeur avec une
belle paire devant toi tu es une belle
paire d'oreillettes la gauche je me
révèle perdre y est parfaitement la
gauche je ne révèlerai de gauche et la
droite c'est pas mal non plus vive la
droite vous faites aussi demanderait ce
matin aux jurés une relative clémence
envers monsieur banny champ car après
tout après tout ce serait trop facile
d'accuser un malheureux imbécile de se
déguiser en flic
alors que l'exemple vient de haut et de
partout quoi
et de quoi et de partout à boire tout
car enfin guillaume tripote nes quoi
chez nous que les chasseurs d'éléphants
se déguisant meneur d'hommes pourraient
ce point chez nous qu'un clown grotesque
se déguise en chef du parti des
travailleurs n'est ce point chez nous
que des pintades laquelle se déguisant
speakerine l'espoir chez nous que des
handicapés mentaux sautillant se
déguisant chanteur un message n'est ce
point chez nous que d'anciens margoulins
ibérique se déguisant l'avocat de la
défense du respect chez nous enfin que
d'anciens journalistes aux petits ce qui
m'a rajouté un truc respect chez nous un
banc par ailleurs on reproche à l'accusé
ses amours boulevardière qui le
pousserait périodiquement à abriter son
talent dans les inévitables placardé
samedi théâtre télévisée nord dans un
lit
là d'un bleu spectatrice d'un bleu
spectatrice post ménopausique viennent
secouer leur dentier en gloussant
doucement une dernière fois tandis que
daniel prévost jaillit de de souligner
en grimaçant sans retenue pour assurer
la pitance de ces chers petits et de son
humble épouse qui reste à la maison pour
cultiver son âme
mais si la théâtre pardon pour qu'il
tirait son homme
c'est une image mais c'est un théâtre
qui en vaut un autre et que celui qui ne
s'est jamais emmerdé dans une maison de
la culture pour lui jette la première
pierre
en attendant je suggère qu'on coupe la
tête de roger hart et de donald caldwell
dans une mise en scène d'alain
peyrefitte
les décors sont du docteur guillotin peu
non
[Musique]